[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich hatte vor ein paar Jahren mal eine Schneetorte gemacht
und das war auch oder ist bis heute sogar noch
Murats Lieblingstorte.
Und das ist schon ein paar Jährchen her.
Gibt es auch noch auf meinem Kanal.
Aber ich dachte mir irgendwie,
wir müssen mal eine Schneetorte 2.0 machen.
Also lehne ich diese Torte heute
an meine Schneetorte von damals an.
Ich will sie aber ein bisschen moderner gestalten.
Vielleicht ein Naked Cake. Mal schauen.
Ich habe mich noch nicht so ganz entschieden.
Jedenfalls habe ich damals eine Wiener Masse gemacht.
Heute mache ich einen Rührkuchen eher.
Das ist ein bisschen einfacher.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt die Zutaten.
Wir starten mit dem Kuchen
und danach gehen wir Richtung Füllung und Creme
und dann entsteht die Torte einfach so
während dem Backprozess.
Ich verwende für den Rührkuchen
vier Eier,
150 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und ein paar Tropfen Bittermandelaroma,
200 Gramm Buttermilch,
200 Gramm Butter,
130 Gramm Mandeln.
Und hier habe ich dann noch
300 Gramm Mehl
und zwei Teelöffel Backpulver.
Das Erste, was ich machen werde, ist
– ich habe hier die Mandeln bereits fein gemahlen.
Ich mahle die auch immer gerne selber,
weil sie dann einfach viel aromatischer schmecken.
Und die könnt ihr jetzt noch intensivieren,
also das Aroma intensivieren,
wenn ihr die jetzt in einer Pfanne röstet ohne Fett.
Hier jetzt einfach auf mittelhohe Stufe.
Dann immer mal wieder schwenken.
Und dann so lange rösten, bis sie einfach lecker duften.
Und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich hier drüben schon mal
die Eier verrühren
– die sind schön zimmerwarm,
so lassen sie sich super aufschlagen –
mit Salz und Zucker,
mit etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Ich weiß gar nicht. Hatte ich damals schon Vanilleextrakt?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ist echt schon lange her.
Bittermandelaroma.
Ihr könnt auch, wenn ihr wollt,
statt Bittermandelaroma Amaretto nehmen.
Dann nehmt ihr einfach ein bisschen von der Buttermilch weg
und fügt Amaretto dazu,
weil man einfach dadurch
diesen typischen Mandelgeschmack noch mal hervorhebt.
Und die Masse wird jetzt so etwa fünf bis sechs Minuten
– es kann auch sein, dass ihr mit dem Handrührgerät
zehn Minuten rühren müsst –
einfach verrührt, bis sie schön weißcremig ist.
Und die Mandeln da drüben nicht vergessen.
Und den Ofen schon vorheizen auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier noch die Butter geschmolzen.
Also nicht heiß werden lassen,
sondern wirklich nur schmelzen.
So ist es perfekt.
Dann kann ich hier den Tortenring schon mal einschlagen.
Der hat 24 cm im Durchmesser.
Und der Teig ist halt ein recht flüssiger Teig.
Deswegen vorher einschlagen.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich jetzt hier die Buttermilch dazu geben.
Und ihr seht, das ist wirklich schön luftig.
Dann die Butter mit rein.
Ihr könnt auch Öl nehmen.
Aber Butter ist sehr lecker.
Kurz einrühren.
Und dann kann ich schon mal
das Mehl mit dem Backpulver sieben.
[Musik]
Also Mehl dazu sieben mit Backpulver.
Dann die abgekühlten Mandeln dazu.
Und alles vorsichtig unterheben.
[Musik]
Noch 30 Sekunden müsst ihr still sein.
>> MURAT: Kriegst du das hin noch mal?
Pass auf!
>> SALLY: Stille Post.
Ab jetzt.
[Musik]
Oje!
Und jetzt einfach den Teig hier reinfüllen.
Hintergrundkulisse, egal.
Die Männer, ich kriege sie nicht mehr still.
Ich kriege sie nicht mehr still.
Und dann kommt der Kuchen in den Backofen.
Später mache ich die Stäbchenprobe,
lasse ihn abkühlen
und dann geht es mit der Füllung weiter.
Okay, Jungs, jetzt könnt ihr reden und ausflippen.
>> DENNIS: Wuh!
>> MURAT: Das haben wir jetzt lang gemacht.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt schön abgekühlt.
Jetzt kann ich ihn hier herauslösen.
Ich habe ihn auch gerade kurz in den Kühlschrank gestellt,
damit er sich gleich einfacher schneiden lässt.
Also hier einfach mit so einem Tortenringmesser
den Rand lösen.
Das Backpapier öffnen
und drunter wegziehen,
also einfach umschlagen.
Und dann den Ring entfernen.
Ta-daa!
Und einmal halbieren.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Der kommt kurz zur Seite.
Und dann geht es jetzt direkt an die Fruchtfüllung.
Ich hatte auch damals
eine Fruchtfüllung mit Himbeeren und Kirschsaft.
Diesmal habe ich jetzt noch Kirschen mit rein
und binde das Ganze mit Agar Agar,
also mit einem pflanzlichen Geliermittel.
Ich nehme für die Füllung
300 Gramm Kirschsaft,
etwas Agar Agar,
50 Gramm Zucker,
eine halbe Zimtstange,
ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb,
300 Gramm Kirschen aus dem TK
und 400 Gramm Himbeeren aus dem TK.
Jetzt gebe ich den Kirschsaft in den Topf.
Und ich habe jetzt hier Kirschsaft von Kirschen aus dem Glas,
– die habe ich jetzt in den Kühlschrank gestellt
zum Weiterverwenden –
nehme aber die Kirschen aus dem TK,
weil die einfach eine schönere Farbe haben.
Also ich möchte, dass es schön richtig rot wird.
Hier noch mein Agar Agar.
Dann Zucker und die Zimtstange.
Und etwas Zitronenabrieb.
[Musik]
Und bei Agar Agar müsst ihr einfach nur beachten,
dass ihr die Masse gleich aufkochen lasst
und dann muss es zwei Minuten lang sprudelnd kochen,
damit es einfach schön wirken kann.
Die Alternative dazu wäre Gelatine.
Könnt ihr auch nehmen.
Aber ich bevorzuge jetzt hier einfach die pflanzliche Variante.
So.
Und die Zimtstange, die entferne ich dann nach dem Kochen.
Denn jetzt kann sie schön ihr Aroma abgeben
und dann nehme ich sie raus.
Wenn ich hier jetzt Zimtpulver nehme,
dann habe ich halt später
dieses Pulvrige auch in der Fruchtfüllung
und das schmeckt mir da jetzt nicht so gut.
Deswegen wirklich schön mit der Zimtstange einfach würzen.
Nicht zu lange drin lassen.
Die Torte soll ja jetzt nicht weihnachtlich werden,
sondern einfach nur so einen Hauch an Zimt
eben dazugewinnen.
Sobald das hier kocht,
dann auch wirklich die Uhr stellen.
Denn die zwei Minuten sind wirklich superwichtig.
Und ich kann jetzt hier schon mal
den Tortenring um den Boden legen.
Also ich bin schon noch dabei, einen Naked Cake zu machen.
Und ich probiere jetzt mal Folgendes.
Huch!
Das kenne ich aus Konditoreien nämlich so,
dass man auch gerne eine Tortenrandfolie benutzt,
um später den Rand wirklich ganz sauber wegzubekommen.
Das machen wir jetzt heute hier mal.
Denn ich glaube, dass das ganz gut ist für den Effekt,
den ich erzielen möchte.
Und die Folie, die ist auch wirklich superstabil.
Die könnt ihr auch mehrfach verwenden.
Ihr seht es ja auch.
Ich habe hier die kleineren schon benutzt,
habe sie einfach wieder abgewaschen,
zusammengerollt und innen reingesteckt.
Da nehme ich jetzt die 10 cm hohe,
stelle dann den Ring außen herum
zum Stabilisieren eben.
Hier immer mal rühren.
Fertig.
Jetzt nehme ich hier die Zimtstange raus.
Die könnt ihr theoretisch einfach abwaschen
und dann noch mal weiter benutzen.
Und ich gebe jetzt hier die kalten Früchte rein.
Dadurch kühlt die Masse eben auch schön und schnell ab.
Die Himbeeren mit rein.
Und ich habe jetzt die Masse auch gar nicht so sehr gesüßt.
Denn die Fruchtfüllung,
da finde ich es immer ganz gut,
wenn die so ein bisschen säuerlich bleibt
und wenn dann die Creme einfach schön süß ist.
Und dann passt alles perfekt zueinander.
Was ich hier jetzt machen werde,
ist eine kleine Gelierprobe.
Gelierprobe heißt,
ich nehme einen Teil von dieser flüssigen Masse
gebe es in einen kleinen Teller
und den stelle ich jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Und wenn der innerhalb von einer Minute ungefähr fest wird,
weiß ich, die Masse wird fest,
und kann sie weiter verarbeiten.
Wenn ich jetzt sehen würde, die wird nicht fest,
dann sollte ich noch mal etwas Agar Agar dazu geben,
noch mal schön aufkochen lassen
und dann eben weiter benutzen.
[Musik]
Die wird super fest.
Das gebe ich jetzt hier gerade noch mal mit rein.
Dann kann es sich noch mal schön auflösen.
So.
Und dadurch, dass ich jetzt
diese gefrorenen Früchte reingegeben habe,
ist die Masse auch nicht mehr heiß.
Das heißt, ich kann die jetzt hier direkt
auf dem Tortenboden verteilen.
Jetzt schön sauber arbeiten,
wenn es ein Naked Cake werden soll.
Also den Rand
im besten Falle nicht vollspritzen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt sofort verstreichen,
dass es überall schön glatt ist.
Agar Agar wird nämlich superschnell fest,
also ganz anders als Gelatine.
Hat natürlich Vor- und Nachteile.
Also eigentlich bei der Kühlzeit bei Torten ist es ein Vorteil.
Bei der Verarbeitung muss man sich einfach beeilen.
Da ist es ein
kleiner Nach-, aber auch Vorteil.
So. Jetzt stelle ich die Torte in den Kühlschrank
und kann in der Zwischenzeit schon mal die Creme machen.
Denn, wie gesagt, Agar Agar wird schnell kalt und fest.
Für die Creme nehme ich
500 Gramm Mascarpone,
250 Gramm Quark,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
80 Gramm Puderzucker,
400 Gramm Sahne
und etwas San-apart.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Unfall,
aber ist es nicht.
Die Zutaten hat heute
nicht die Sally gerichtet.
>> JOSH: Ich war es nicht.
>> SALLY: Josh war es auch nicht.
Der Josh, der kann das nämlich richtig gut.
Ich sage es nicht, wer es war.
Ich sage es nicht.
Ich sage nicht, wer die Mascarpone
in diese Form gebracht hat.
Ja.
Erfahrt ihr nicht.
Mascarpone und Quark sind jetzt hier in der Schüssel.
Dann kommt das Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Puderzucker.
Jetzt kurz cremig rühren.
Und jetzt gieße ich hier langsam die Sahne dazu.
Was man natürlich immer machen kann, ist,
die Sahne steif schlagen und dann unterheben.
Aber ich habe mir das irgendwann abgewöhnt.
Also irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht:
"Nee, warum eigentlich?
Wir schlagen das einfach zusammen steif und luftig."
Und sobald sich alles vermischt hat, noch San-apart
oder Sahnesteif dazu geben
und schön steif schlagen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier den Kuchen
– die Torte.
Und da gebe ich jetzt
etwa ein Drittel der Creme drauf.
Schön verstreichen.
[Musik]
Und, damit hier jetzt der Rand auch schön sauber ist,
nehme ich einen Teigschaber
– ich habe ja doch ein bisschen gekleckert –
und kann jetzt hier den Rand einfach noch mal schön säubern.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt hier den Kuchen drauf,
also den zweiten Tortenboden.
Oh! Der ist mir jetzt ein bisschen gerissen.
Hoppala!
Macht nichts.
Der hat zwar jetzt diese Wölbung,
aber das finde ich jetzt nicht schlimm.
Also dann hat er halt in der Mitte so eine kleine Kuppel.
Aber ist nicht schlimm.
Jetzt...
Jetzt ist da ehrlich
ein Krümel reingerutscht.
>> JOSH: Hat doch schön gepasst.
>> SALLY: Nee, nee, nee.
Ich wollte euch nur einen kleinen Blick hierein gewähren.
>> JOSH: Sieht schön aus.
>> SALLY: Tja.
Wie heißt das im Kino immer? Sneak Peek.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Jetzt das zweite Drittel der Creme.
Das überlege ich jetzt übrigens gerade im On.
Also ich überlege jetzt gerade, wie die Torte aussieht.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht,
die Restcreme nehme ich dann,
fülle sie in einen Spritzbeutel
und mache so Spritztupfen drauf.
Ja!
Und hier wieder schön glatt streichen,
dass ihr eine glatte Oberfläche habt.
[Musik]
Wenn das mit dem Glattstreichen
übrigens nicht so ganz funktioniert,
also ihr nehmt einfach
diese tiefe Tortenringpalette,
diese Streichpalette, setzt die an und dreht dann einfach.
Also mit der Drehplatte geht es halt echt perfekt,
weil da muss man echt nicht so wirklich viel machen.
Ansonsten könnt ihr auch
einen kleinen Crashkurs besuchen
beim
Maurer eures Vertrauens.
Der kann das auch.
Ich glaube, Maurer könnten echt die besten Torten machen.
Oder, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Schon so spachteln.
>> JOSH: Ein Stuckateur bestimmt auch.
>> SALLY: Ein Stuckateurbetrieb.
So eine Stuckleiste dann noch machen.
Ist schon nicht schlecht.
Hier den Rand wieder säubern.
[Musik]
Ich bin heute ein bisschen ein Wirbelwind, gell?
Man merkt es, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Wir kriegen gleich Besuch und daher
– dafür ist auch die Torte.
Huch! Heute bin ich ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Irgendwann erfahrt ihr warum.
Vielleicht.
Jetzt geht die Schere nicht.
Die Schere geht nicht!
Okay.
Jetzt nehme ich hier diese Lochtülle.
Die hat 16 mm
im Durchmesser.
Ich denke, das passt.
Und dann knickt ihr die Spitze um.
Es kommt in den Spritzbeutel.
Warum der Knick?
Damit die Creme unten nicht ausläuft.
Die würde jetzt nicht auslaufen,
aber so eine flüssigere schon.
Die schon.
Jetzt machen wir eine schnelle Deko,
die aber wunderschön ist.
Okay.
Jetzt hier oben festdrehen.
Das sind übrigens Einwegspritzbeutel.
Aber die könnt ihr Mehrweg benutzen.
Also die sind echt superstabil.
Ich wasche die dann auch einfach aus.
Und jetzt dreht ihr hier oben den Spritzbeutel zu.
Diese Hand,
die führt den Druck aus.
Die Hand führt.
Und immer darauf achten,
die Sahne dann nicht so weich zu machen.
Also hier drücke ich die Creme raus, hier oben,
und unten führe ich einfach.
Den Spritzbeutel schön senkrecht halten,
also nicht so.
Denn dann bekommt ihr keine schönen Spitzen.
Und dann lasse ich, glaube ich, schon ein bisschen Rand
und mache hier so kleine Tupfen drauf
komplett auf die ganze Torte.
[Musik]
Wenn dann hier oben wenig Creme drin ist,
drücke ich die Creme runter,
drehe es noch mal schön fest.
Und dann habt ihr immer
den perfekten Druck nämlich auch auf die Torte.
[Musik]
Torte ist erst mal fertig,
kommt in den Kühlschrank
– bei mir sogar in den Gefrierschrank,
weil es dann schneller geht.
Und dann werde ich sie gleich rauslösen,
mit Baiser,
mit so kleinen Baiserstückchen,
die kommen dann
– oh, die machen wir in Slow Motion drauf!
Okay.
Ich mache es dann so:
Wir lösen den Ring später.
Die Folie bleibt dran.
Wir richten es am Set an.
Es kommen Baiserstückchen.
Die werden drübergebröselt, mit Glitzerschnee bestreut.
Und dann können wir die Torte probieren.
Das ist doch mal ein Plan.
[Musik]
Habt ihr das gesehen,
wie der Schnee da so drübergefallen ist?
Und dann habe ich noch Glitzerschnee drüber.
Das sieht man jetzt über die Kamera nicht so gut,
aber in echt sieht man es echt gut.
So, Murat, du darfst probieren.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Woran erinnert dich diese Torte?
>> MURAT: Woran?
Die hast du vor drei Jahren oder so was gemacht, gell?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und
war lecker.
Es war eine meiner Lieblingstorten.
>> SALLY: Wie hieß die?
>> MURAT: Schneetorte.
>> SALLY: An die erinnerst du dich,
aber nicht an unseren Hochzeitstag?
>> MURAT: Ja,
den habe ich vergessen.
Nicht schlimm.
Aber an die Torte kann ich mich erinnern.
Ich kann mich
– ich kann Emotionen mit Torten verbinden.
>> SALLY: Und wir hatten die sogar
auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt damals.
Weißt du das auch noch?
>> MURAT: Nee, habe ich auch vergessen.
>> SALLY: Achje!
>> MURAT: Ich bin total vergesslich. Es tut mir leid.
Sieht aber auch genial aus!
Ich bin mal gespannt,
wie die so schmeckt.
>> SALLY: So. Und dann immer das Messer sauber machen,
damit der Anschnitt schön sauber ist.
>> MURAT: Die sieht aber ein bisschen größer aus als die.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich habe die jetzt moderner gemacht.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Die damals, die war so ein bisschen klassischer.
Und die ist jetzt moderner, ein Naked Cake.
>> MURAT: Oh, ich liebe das absolut!
Naked Cake ist nichts Schlimmes.
Das ist nur die Art des Kuchens.
>> SALLY: Nur die Torte ist nackt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
So sieht sie aus.
>> MURAT: Guck mal, Josh. Guck mal kurz rein.
Den Anschnitt.
Also besser hätte ich es nicht selber machen können.
Selber hätte ich es nicht besser machen können, meine ich.
Genau.
>> JOSH: Gut.
>> SALLY: Warte, die Spitze gehört noch zu dir.
Okay, probier mal.
>> MURAT: Und muss ich dann wissen, was drin ist.
>> SALLY: Nö.
Also eigentlich musst du so einmal so durch,
so alle,
alle Bestandteile zusammen.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich meine, die heißt zwar Schneetorte,
aber man kann sie schon auch im Sommer essen, oder?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sommer, Herbst.
jahreszeitlos.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und?
>> MURAT: Hammer! Wirklich!
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Wirklich genial!
>> SALLY: Sehr gut!
>> MURAT: Das ist einer meiner...
Wirklich! Das war auch eines deiner meistgeklickten Videos.
Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Aber ich habe sie ein bisschen verändert.
Damals eher so Wiener Masse, heute so ein Rührölteig.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Auch gut?
>> SALLY: Okay.
Sehr gut.
Also, falls ihr die Torte nachmachen wollt,
dann findet ihr das Rezept
in meiner Sallys Welt App oder auf sallys-blog.de.
Probiert sie auf jeden Fall mal aus!
Gerne diese Version oder auch die alte Version,
die ich damals gemacht habe vor vier, fünf Jahren.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Müsste ich selber noch mal nachgucken.
Und dann könnt ihr die Bilder gerne posten
und ich schaue sie mir an.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Ich glaube...
>> SALLY: Langsam essen!
Ich mache jetzt noch einen Kaffee dazu. Iss langsam!
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, damit bist du auf jeder Party
– bist du schon mal...
>> SALLY: Auf jeden Fall!
Und vor allem, ihr habt ja gesehen,
mit dieser Tortenrandfolie bekommt eben diesen tollen Effekt,
dass sie wirklich richtig schön glatt wird außen.
Man kann sie dann auch mit der Folie mitnehmen
und die Folie auch wiederverwerten.
Also nicht wegschmeißen!
Wir werden sie auch gleich auswaschen.
Und dann habt ihr echt was Wunderschönes.
Und den Schnee vielleicht auch kurz vor dem Verzehr drauf.
>> MURAT: Ich werde sie wahrscheinlich auswaschen müssen.
Also...
>> SALLY: Vielleicht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und den Schnee so kurz vor Verzehr draufgeben,
damit die Baiserstückchen noch so schön knusprig bleiben.
Okay.
>> MURAT: Habe ich gerade den Kuchen weggehauen?
>> SALLY: Ja, mach langsam.
Wir teilen die jetzt.
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Hammer!
Ich würde dich noch mal heiraten.
>> SALLY: Oh!
[Musik]